you want to go now to Nicole Killian
who's in Atlanta following another
crucial Senate race could determine
control of the senate in the state of
Georgia this time Nicole good morning
hey good morning to you Tony and you
know the senate race continues to be
extremely close the latest polls show
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock and
his Republican Challenger Herschel
Walker are deadlocked and turnout for
early voting has been at a record pace
one week out from election day a fierce
fight to the finish it is up to us to
get out and vote to put the right people
in not just Herschel Walker because I'm
going to win between Senate GOP
Challenger Herschel Walker and
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock I
think that the differences
between me and my opponent are Stark I
think Character Matters if the choice is
so Stark why is this race so close I
think that um
many people in our country and in our
state
uh are often either wearing a blue
jersey or a red jersey and you look at
Herschel Walker you see a study in
contrast
with seven days to go there's a full
court press to get out the vote
particularly among African-Americans who
make up about a third of the state's
electorate
from a souls to the poles Caravan it's
more like a think of a church picnic a
church homecoming family reunion we all
do it together
to college mixers we got 12 days Natasha
Brown is a co-founder of black voters
matter which has launched a bus tour in
key Battlegrounds it's really important
that we send a message not only that we
won't back down and we won't Black down
but that there is a new Coalition Rising
while the peach state has seen record
turnout in early voting there are
lingering concerns after a new voting
law took effect last year that allows
unlimited challenges to the voter rolls
Travis Barber says he got a red flag
when he recently tried to cast his
ballot one of more than 64 thousand
voters whose eligibility was challenged
this year under the new law I was
embarrassed I had to be called to the
side while everybody else is coming
through their processes one two three
Brad raffensberger is Georgia's
Secretary of State well I've been very
clear on that we want to make sure that
people are lawful eligible voters in the
state of Georgia
[Applause]
well Travis was able to vote with a
provisional
state
have been a number of frivolous
challenges so they may consider
additional reforms to the law and just a
reminder that If no candidate clears 50
could be headed for a runoff in December
Tony yeah yeah a lot of people expecting
one Nicole thank you very much and a
quick reminder for our viewers midterms
are just one week away we encourage
people to vote and of course watch our
full coverage right here on CBS starting
at 8 pm Eastern on November 8th that's
election day